welcome to Curry's Woods here in Jersey
City thank you
um it was actually originally built for
low-income residents around 1960. wow
and then it was redone in early 2000s so
we've tried to do over the last couple
years is really find Partners to provide
more social services and the farm is
just another opportunity to expand an
ecosystem around Social Services healthy
living healthy diets and that's what
we're trying to do here with our
partnership with arrow Farms that is so
cool this is Maury and Maury is the
point person and responsible for the
program
while the mayor takes care of some
business I want to spend some time with
Maury and see how this operation works
I'm excited to see what you're up to all
right we're going to start the
harvesting process oh perfect yeah get
comfortable
scissors so what are we harvesting here
this is micro broccoli most of the time
we're introducing the community to
microgreens for the very first time
indoor Farms like the one here at this
community center are an ideal way to
grow nutrients dance leafy
green all year round
it's like giving a little haircut so you
just you just kind of pinch off a little
bit cool it's like a Chia Pet yes
and micro greens can provide up to 40
times more nutrients than fold mature
sized vegetables so how did you end up
doing this kind of community-based work
I have been doing community work in
Jersey City for almost 15 years and so I
got very involved in city parks and the
food conversation since I'm a chef I
love introducing people to new foods and
getting them to like change their
perspective it's kind of you know
bridging that Gap I mean that's one of
the beautiful things about this program
is it's bringing the food directly into
the neighborhoods who need them the most
I feel like for most people who grow
food as a farmer you don't really get to
see the people that you're serving
actually try the food that you're
growing that's that's what I love most
you know we're using greens to
facilitate a larger conversation about
what health means because what health
means to me is different from what it
means to you different from the next
person
okay this looks really good so who who
did we just Harvest these greens for we
have two of my favorite members coming
over Terry and Bernadette now we're
gonna roll this up just like you're
rolling a big spring roll nice and tight
tight okay oh it's like satisfying it's
like a little hairy I don't know if I'd
love it or if I hate it it's slightly
disturbing it is
so that's it that looks so ridiculous
hey ladies hi you're just in time
so here's your uh greens for the week
this is micro broccoli having this right
in the neighborhood I feel like is
incredible and even more than that
teaching people how to grow this for
themselves
well this is just awesome this is the
best it's convenient it's it's a game
changer I'm a vegetarian slash vegan and
I love it and I'm trying to get my
community to love it like me
and it's a good thing for our children
to learn how to grow their own
vegetables this is what I love just
seeing how farming brings communities
together it's so important to me
[Music]
thank you